I was raised in western Massachusetts,
I am the child of two southerners and my
brother is also southern and my family
is southern way back before the
mayflower.
So I was the only Yankee in the family
for all generations.
And it,
um,
it definitely shaped me and my taste.
I was the only little Yankee boy who
liked boiled peanuts and puts a salted
peanuts in his coke and I'm liked grits
for breakfast.
Okay.
Well,
southerners I think have,
um,
a number of traditions,
one of which is a storytelling.
So,
um,
my southern relations when we get
together,
I mean it's just one story after
another,
after another,
after another Thanksgiving when I go
down to visit my uncle Bob and aunt
render and all the cousins are there.
My stomach will hurt for days afterward
because it's just so funny and they're
all great storytellers and that's kind
of how a family knowledge is passed on
from generation to generation is through
stories.
Um,
you know,
I mean,
it's a cliche,
but,
um,
there's a certain level of dysfunction I
suppose that goes along with being part
of a southern family secrets.
And,
and,
and all these entanglements
and there's a,
uh,
there's a sort of gentility a courtesy.
I mean,
I was very polite as a child.
I'm very well mannered as a child and
um,
that's something else that you find
probably it all started with the,
with the astors,
you know,
in the vanderbilts in New York City in
the gilded age when society was
constructed of layers upon layers upon
layers of etiquette.
I mean,
you,
you didn't call somebody on the phone or
you didn't text them and say,
let's go grab lunch.
You would have your,
Your Person Send Your handwritten note
over by carriage to your acquaintances
or your friend's house.
And they would receive the note and
respond in kind.
And they were just very,
um,
many layers to society and how we
behaved and how we reacted
appropriately.
Now because New York is an,
always has been sort of the,
uh,
the design geist from which,
you know,
everything radiates out.
This is sort of the taste center and the
design center of America.
Um,
and certainly was back then,
I think a lot of people emulated a,
that stratified sort of concept of
society and um,
Chicago certainly did,
you know,
the big families began behaving as New
Yorkers did and then as,
as society spread west and happened in
the west coast as well and down south.
And it's interesting because,
um,
these,
these manners,
you know,
a lot of them became of course outdated
over time.
Life became more casual,
you know,
casual Friday took over.
But in the south,
what you find is that these,
um,
these manners still remain.
Um,
last Thanksgiving I was driving down a
dirt road in Alabama.
Is that a red clay road?
Very Narrow d dog,
Alabama,
you know,
where there are alligators in the
backyard and this big pickup truck,
like in Ford,
f three,
five was approaching me.
And um,
so it was me and my boyfriend and our
two French bulldogs.
And I'm thinking,
okay,
this is the part where the good old boy
pulls the fags over,
shoots him and takes the dogs.
And so as this truck gets closer and
closer,
it's got the big headlights,
you know,
on the top,
I see the driver is wearing camouflage,
including a camouflage hat.
So I'm thinking,
well,
this is it.
We're going to die.
And just as we passed the trucker goes
like this
and moves on.
And I realized at that moment it was an
epiphany and I realized the last
gentleman,
these are the last true gentlemen,
are the southern good old boys because
their mamas taught them to behave,
you know?
Yes ma'am.
Thank you ma'am.
No Sir.
Thank you sir.
And that's pretty much how it is in the
shelf.
And that's why I love the south.
I love,
I love this APP.
I don't think I've inherited the um,
you know,
the gothic literary sensibility sort of
almost dated to Eudora welty and
flannery o'connor.
It's a,
it's a south that doesn't quite exist as
it did.
Certainly there are pockets,
um,
but because I didn't live in the south,
I didn't experience,
you know,
the Spanish moss hanging off the trees
and the sort of sweltering day days in
that sort of drowsy,
you know.
And the sort of sweet tea and um,
I have a deep appreciation for it.
I mean,
one of my favorite authors is um,
Carson mccullers and I think I'm,
the member of the wedding is just one of
the most perfect books ever written.
Um,
and it really for me,
captures that flavor.
I don't know if you would call it a
gothic southern novel,
but it certainly captures that dee dee
just sort of almost the central south
and melancholy quality.
So I myself don't think of myself as a
southern writer,
although there are certain things about
me that are definitely a bitter
definitely southern that are there as a
result of,
um,
you know,
having southern parents and having
southern relatives.